now poland's interior ministry says a
hundred thousand ukrainians have poured
into the country since the russian
assault began many have been taking
temporary shelter in halls and train
stations zane basravi is live for us now
from eastern poland where ukrainians are
crossing the border zane bring us up to
date on what's happening there
well housing we're inside the train
station in the town of shemeshla a small
train station relatively speaking and
otherwise mid-sized town has become a
major hub of activity as ukrainian
refugees continue to stream across the
border last night we reported us an
estimated 30 000 people across now we're
saying a hundred thousand which
represents the speed of how things are
really picking up around here now i want
to give you some more latest information
that we're hearing from the government
is that now all border crossings are
open to foot traffic the government here
knows that people are stuck at the
border there they're stuck on the
ukrainian side processing times are
taking a long time they're having to
abandon cars rail lines are all
overwhelmed so a lot of people are
ditching everything and walking so
they've reopened all borders to foot
traffic and when people cross the border
by rail car or foot this is the kind of
place they come to first now trains from
la viv are coming here and when they
come here places like these are usually
the first time they have a chance to
have any kind of help there's official
help and unofficial help we're seeing
medical facilities here we're seeing
people handing out food and and drink
and all kinds of other
nourishment here we're also seeing
plenty of private citizens offering uh
to give people shelter and rides all
across europe we've had we've seen
people putting up signs saying uh free
rides and free housing inside poland in
places like krakow there's a man here
that has a sign posted he's offering
free transport uh
outside of
the city elsewhere into poland as well
as free
nights of stay for anyone who's coming
in and needs a place to stay there's so
many volunteers here that are offering
rides to
prague berlin denmark really the
outpouring of help from europeans for
other europeans really gives you a sense
of the fact that this conflict is not
just russia versus ukraine this is
russia versus europe we're just going to
walk down this hall to give you a sense
of the space here
we've got another
makeshift food station set up here uh
people in the hall just ahead of us are
registering to
get rides to elsewhere in europe where
they have friends and family some people
have nowhere to go
but are being assisted here by polish
authorities to try to get them some kind
of resources now we've seen reports of a
hundred thousand people coming and even
though there are uh hundreds of people
at this train station
they don't stay around very long and
that's because we're we're seeing a lot
of people being brought in via train
there's just another train that's come
in now there's another one expected in a
couple of hours they don't stay here
very long they're being moved out
elsewhere into poland elsewhere into
europe by volunteers as well as official
polish government uh uh agencies and
ngos and that's all part of the help
that ukrainians are receiving we've met
with uh
uh several people here they're
frustrated they're tired they're scared
one of the stories we heard from a group
of young women
with children is that they had to leave
their husbands behind at the border and
they were very aware of the fact that
this might be the last time that they're
saying farewell to their husbands
men of a certain age men between 18 and
60 are not being allowed to cross over
they're being conscripted into the
ukrainian armed forces
in an effort to continue to push back
against the russian invasion but the
fact of the matter is that many of the
people we've spoken to here say that the
fall of kiev is a foregone conclusion
it's only a matter of time and after
kiev they think large cities like lev
where trains come in
from to this train station they think
those places are just next on the list
for cities that are likely to fall in
this invasion of ukraine by russia
zane thanks very much zane basravi
reporting to us there from a train
station in eastern poland where so many
ukrainians have been arriving